federal agencies are now revealing an
Iranian National with terti was caught
illegally crossing the US northern
border and remained in the country for 6
weeks before being removed it comes as
ice reports 139 known or suspected
terrorists were detained by the
department in the last fiscal year that
number more than doubling fiscal year
2022 Tom fely is the former director of
New York's ice removals and he joins us
now Tom thank you for joining us today
so this arrest highlights what we all
know that there are bad guys terrorists
trying to get in to our country we also
know that this is a highly volatile
period of time in in the world with Wars
and people angry at us all over the
place so how worried are you that there
could be Terror cells forming right now
and and bad people coming in um and and
potentially pulling off something very
deadly good morning thanks for having me
um you know the the southern border is
more of the sexy border if you will it
gets all the attention it gets all the
resources and uh from a strategical
point of view if you look at Canada
Canada has some very liberal Refugee and
Asylum um policies that allow people to
more easily gain access to Canada than
the United States uh so to speak um so a
lot of people who want to come here and
do harm to us actually come to Canada
and then sneak across the northern
border that just doesn't have that many
resources and I can't get into too much
detail obviously but I can tell you the
New York ports of Entry see more uh
nefarious people probably I I I think a
lot more than people would probably uh
suspect without you know giving up too
many Secrets yeah that's so scary and we
know that there are record numbers of
known terrorists that we've caught we
don't know how many are here that we
haven't caught and we know there are
hundreds of thousands of Goda aways
those are people that are trying to
evade us and not turn themselves into to
the border patrol you also expressed
concern that this individual the
specific individual that this this this
man that with links to terrorism that
was caught that he was not held longer
for
questioning well again I don't really
know the specifics of it and we don't
want to really get into what the
processes are for ice dealing with these
individuals that come from foreign
countries that have terrorist ties um
the period does seem a little short uh
hopefully the Intel agencies did get an
opportunity to interview him and uh as
rain some more information and like I've
said before on Fox News I I know there's
terrorist organizations and cells here
uh unfortunately I've had the
opportunity to interview some of them
including Hamas and it's just really
concerning that with a wide open border
and I don't think any argument can be
made that there isn't one we have no
idea who's coming in uh you know people
keep mentioning Goda ways you know how
do you know you had 10,000 Goda ways
because you didn't catch them so like is
it a marble bowl and you're trying to
guess how many are in there for a prize
um they're they're here and you know a
scenario as simple could be you know say
you take 20 American cities five
terrorists in each city which is very
very low number and just say they decide
to you know do what they did in Israel
like Hamas did just driving around
neighbors and start shooting and killing
innocent people that would literally
literally the wheels of American society
would come off and it would be
absolutely Dev devastating to us it's a
real possibility yeah and they don't
seem to care they really don't seem to
care whatever their policy is whatever
this borderless world they want to
create or collapsing our system um
through this illegal immigration
whatever it is matters to them more even
than the politics of a possible terror
attack they are hellbent on doing this
um last word on on on what you think
should happen or what what can
happen I I really don't understand what
the endgame is with this Administration
I mean you can say it's kind of tongue
and Chic we're importing you know
Democrat voters um but most places
everybody knows it's a constitutional
issue illegal aliens can't vote or
shouldn't be voting and I I really just
don't know what the end game is I mean
are you really trying to destroy the
United States of America because you
couldn't have a bigger example of a
trojan horse than what we have going on
right now I than you now that there's no
other explanation it just does not make
sense and I agree this is much bigger
than some you know voting scheme to get
more Democrat voters it's much bigger I
think it's Global and I think we've
already seen that whether it's the UN um
you know these other countries that are
participating the WF the wh this is a
globalist um plot to do this no the NGS
we can't forget about that um Tom fely
thank you for joining us frightening but
important to be aware of what's
Happening thanks for having me have a
great New Year absolutely you too Happy
New Year I'm Steve duy I'm Brian kilme
and I'm Angley aart and click here to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
to catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling
analysis